Thank You mr. president
I want to refer to the three topics that
have been raised the most here the first
one is of course our budget and mff the
second one is brexit and the third one
is the Western Balkan so first of all
what the budget is concerned I think
dear Prime Minister it is very important
that Croatia and the presidency
convinces the council to stick to his
own strategic agenda because and I'm
emphasizing this because we need the
modernization of the budget why this the
budget we have right now has been agreed
on in 2013 you remember the year 2013
because of the worlds the year when
Croatia joined the European Union the
world was completely different in the
year 2013 we did not have any idea of -
it was existing already but we didn't
know anything of it there hasn't been
the migration crisis yet Russia had not
enacted the Crimea and had not started
yet the hybrid war in the Ukraine at
that time we had no Paris climate
agreement we were not speaking of 5g or
artificial intelligence so these few
highlights show the world is completely
different and that we do need a
completely different budget that means
modernization and one message from my
part and I think I have the support of
the Parliament there if the overall
ceiling is too low if the budget in
itself is too small the only way out our
own new resources on the European level
and there is an opportunity to introduce
that with the emission trading system
because the emission the revenues of the
emission trading system will grow so we
will not take anything away from the
Member States on the contrary they'll
have more but we can also allocate on
the European level
the revenues from the emission trading
system to serve the European Green Deal
second topic is indeed brexit your
presidencies the presidency comes at a
crucial time for the brexit negotiations
because we have to make enormous
progress
this is decisive til the summer till the
end of your presidency and here we have
to decide on or it's the UK's choice to
decide on how close or how distant they
want to be from the European Union but
that also means from the single market
so in other terms you cannot have no
free movement and then expect to have
free movement for no free movement for
people and then expect to have free
movement for goods capital or services
it's either all for have a free movement
or none of this is possible you cannot
accept to have a level playing field if
there's a huge divergent in taxation or
social standards or environmental
standards so it is the choice of the UK
how far they want to align or diverge
but this is decisive for for how good
the access to the single market will be
or not
in short it's the old proverb you cannot
have the cake and eat it at the same
time and that the very last point the
Western Balkans is global Faris team are
there this vest Balkans we do have
niched under Jetson s in unserem are
taken in Trece does the West Bank and
zone Navi mulish balances resort mission
- its enriched our kina pirates present
is mystic Roseland dot presenters which
dark Tito Cairo presenters ala meet
their intention they invest Baraka
nudish tartness vodka by spark and so
stock film V Mowgli of irrigated Soutine
this is an older mattress a seasoned avi
Mukerjea nonchalance uber comment
there's a bit in black of not macedonian
on a banyan
am fearful infant not Macedonia Moses a
Naaman vixen whom demolish kites will
have the by Turkish pleasure metal
patient or neurons were
avocadoes schaffen I know that's invite
responses to modernism about and resides
of TOI involved sublime ensue deemed as
were not Macedonian on I bunions after
is an on demand tres owned Indies
Mozilla when Shaheen alles gute a very
presidential president from the Lion at
Isola parola el primo ministro plank of
each Prague Andre gratia Da Vida ladies
and gentlemen dear president first of
all thank you for many reactions many
suggestions many different voice of view
on the current priorities of the
Croatian presidency but also on some
ideas how you will believe we should
tackle the most important political and
legislative dossiers which are on the
agenda let me say a few points at the
end in order to try to collectively
touch some of the matters that you have
raised first of all what is the
philosophy of our first-ever presidency
of the Council we are a bit of a symbol
and a signal I said at the beginning
only 30 years of democracy 28 years of
international recognition seventh year
of membership still catching up with
those who are more developed those who
were in the Union from the start
all those who joined like our neighbors
from Central and Eastern Europe in 2004
and 2007 one of the MEP s mr. Kraft I
think he mentioned first Croatian
President Tudjman
and try to interpret his doctrine I dare
to say that I might know a little bit
better what is the legacy of the first
Croatian president and what he wanted
for Croatia
once we gained our sovereignty for the
future and the perspective it was
actually him 30 years ago on the
of May in the first democratically
composed Croatian Parliament who said
that the European integration is the way
to go and everything we have done in the
last three decades has been the
implementation of this objective we know
what sovereignty means we know what it
means unlike any other country which is
present in this hemicycle what does it
mean to have occupied territory what
does it mean to have a war on your
territory what does it mean to have more
than 16,000 people killed in your own
country almost at the end of the 20th
century we have that experience vivid
and we know that Europe is a project of
peace and cooperation and reconciliation
that's how we address our political
responsibilities today this is very
important to note second we have taken
into account the strategic agenda the
trio program the program of the new
Commission and our own programme
everything that we have put as
priorities is very realistic and
therefore on some of the items we know
that the climate change and the climate
neutral objective until 2015 will be a
driver of our economic transformation it
will become for economy what human
rights are embedded in our foreign
policy and this is what we agreed with a
commission in Zagreb last week we shall
help to address this issue so as to take
into account the different state of play
of our industries our financial
capability our budgetary capabilities in
order to go in the same direction but
not to have negative economic
consequences second on the dossier of
migration which many of you have
mentioned I will say once again and I
repeat this with full understanding that
this is crucial what we must do in the
months ahead of us we had the
arrangement - in Turkey that has managed
to put down the numbers of the illegal
migration on the eastern Mediterranean
and Western Balkans route
compared to 2015-16 data by 98%
98% down this yet these are the numbers
we have which we have now compared to
five years ago only to 2%
how shall we tackle this jointly we
speak about front X of 10,000 border
police my country proportionally perhaps
has more border police than any other
6500 I hear some statements and
allegations which in the reports which
you read or the rumors you hear are
almost to become effect they are not
whenever there was an allegation there
was an investigation there were some
disciplinary measures there is a strong
surveillance within our police to
prevent any violation of human rights or
any behavior which would be contravening
around law European standards or
international conventions this is how we
shall behave but I repeat once again
unlike many other member states we have
said no barbed wire between two friendly
neighboring countries such as Croatia
and Bosnia and Herzegovina and we will
not erect fences between the nations
which are friendly which will always be
together as we were together in the past
and most over we said clearly we will
not erect fences between parts of the
Bosnian Herzegovina border where Croats
lived as constituent people in Bosnia
Herzegovina and Croats on the other side
of the border this will simply not
happen this is our policy and we will
stay behind it but what we want to do is
jointly address the problem either at
the source or at the first point of
entry creation Boston Herzegovina border
is not the first point of entry of
migratory waves let's be very clear
about it this is important to note on
budget the stakes are high we understood
the message of we can't do more with
less finances available that's very
clear but we need to find a common con
census if we are to embark on the new
own resources by many analysis by many
reports or very able people in a number
of years behind us
this might seem the only way to address
as author Allah says the modernization
expectations of what we can finance
joint this is key on demography if there
is one element political which I would
like to be as a legacy of Croatia in
this six months and also together with
the Commission and given the dubravka
has this expresses very best portfolio
first time ever in the history of the
European Union because we feel this is
an existential question for the European
Union for almost half of our member
states who do have a negative natural
growth such as my country I think as a
set of tools with great grades and
sensitiveness of the president of the
Commission who knows in her previous
roles how important this issue is how we
can combine policy measures which have
proved to be efficient in other
countries how we can offer them to those
that have a difficulty this is the idea
the population from less developed
countries to more developed from rural
area areas to urban areas these are our
common problems and we should address
them joint on the Western Balkans and
the issue of enlargement we are not
naive
we are not unrealistic I know more
perhaps than anybody since I've been
dealing with this issue for almost 30
years
the level of enthusiasm that the West
with the open hands has offered to the
Central and Eastern European countries
in the 90s will never happen again to
those who would like to join but what we
need to do is intelligently structured
the process for next 10 years to steer
this process to pilot it to give an
ambitious agenda for those who want to
reform transform and attain the
standards that we have in the European
Union this is the idea behind the summit
that we want to organize in Zagreb and
therefore I say for those who are afraid
of saying yes to the opening of the
intergovernmental conference with
Albania and nor
Macedonia we know it it's a complex
legal process with so many possibilities
to either suspend or to reverse or to
ask more or to build another requirement
in this exercise that it is just a start
of a marathon it's not a senseless sweet
a novel we have to be clear about it the
enlargement doesn't happen overnight it
happens after years of long reformed
process and careful scrutiny by the
Commission and the input of the member
states in that respect I don't want any
of the countries in our neighborhood to
be forgotten
especially Bosnia and Herzegovina who is
strategic for my country I would also
mention Ukraine because you mentioned it
Orsola now I think in the context of the
Eastern Partnership and everything we
had dealt from 2013 and 14 until now we
should adequately address it their own
ambitions for the territorial integrity
but also for their reforms in the
European perspective which we should
support one word and breaks it I see
that Michelle is here and this topic is
just after our debate I think the most
important element in last
three-and-a-half years was the unity of
the 27 we remained united with full
solidarity extended especially to the
most concerned countries such as Ireland
in the 11 months ahead of us with an
intelligently drafted and crafted
negotiated framework I think we can
attain a good agreement as a starting
point for future relations we should not
pretend that in an unprecedented
situation we can solve with the first
contractual relations everything we'd
like to do in the future
after the divorce that is happening
literally in three weeks and therefore
we will help you as the council on the
proposal of the Commission to find the
right balance for the completion in the
months to come
finally I just want to reiterate that
all of our services all of our ministers
government MEP swak who are here and I
thank them for their contributions are
will be at your disposal
to have a good dialogue together and to
reach compromises this is one of the
objectives of the European democracy
this is the role of the European
Parliament this is the role of the
Member States within the council and
also the facilitating and the leadership
role that the European Commission has I
thank you very much dear president for
this opportunity for having been with
you here today in Strasbourg again and
as you many said my friends which is a
very dear institution to me thank you
grazie primo ministro plank of each
naturalmente uri para el sol lavoro a
urea to terrazzo squadra de gobierno /
questa periodo coach importante para una
una europaea la discusión su questo
Punto excuse
[Music]